today we will be awarding trooper micah  may with two certificates of  commendation  this is to certify that the director of  public safety and the chief of the  nevada highway patrol  have awarded the medal of valor and the  purple heart  to trooper micah may the certificate of  commendation reads  on july 27 2021 at approximately 11  20 hours troopers were notified of an  armed robbery carjacking that occurred  on las vegas boulevard and sunset road  troopers discovered the vehicle and a  lengthy pursuit ensued  trooper may attempted to deploy stop  sticks on interstate 15 near the neon  gateway  when the fleeing felon struck him and  continued  trooper may was transported to umc where  he succumbed  to the injury sustained in the assault  with a deadly weapon  these medals will be presented to joanna  may  by major martin molesko  you